welcome both of you to Miami Jennifer
Lopez and Shakira are ready to rock
Miami come Sunday the dual Super Bowl
halftime performers held a press
conference on Thursday sharing what this
opportunity means to them when I was
living in Barranquilla my hometown as a
little girl no one would have thought
that I would end up performing at the
Super Bowl one day I just think that
this is a palpable example of how
anything is possible
really I know my mom and dad were we
were a football family every Sunday we'd
watch the Jets I think if you ask them
you know would you rather have the Jets
in the Super Bowl this year or to see
their daughter standing up there
representing women and Latinas and
Americans and everything that I am and
that Shakira is I think they would be
they would pick this the Chiefs in the
49ers are run by women and then you got
two women headlining the halftime show
so it's just that statement alone for me
is empowering I'm very proud to be able
to to help set and push forth that
message it's a message that they hope
will especially resonate with young
latinas I think that Jo and I are are
here redefining paradigms about age
about race about background it doesn't
really matter where you're from how old
you are or where you come from what
matters is the message you have what you
have to say you know and we're here we
have a lot of stuff to say
[Music]
JLo and Shaq have been gearing up to
take the stage for weeks when we
finished the first run-through
you know Shakira latina she was like
that was amazing and I was like no you
were amazing and I think it's we it was
very she was like it's different what we
do and I say well it's very secure and
it's very Jennifer and I think that's
what you're gonna get from the
performance it's a lot of energy it's
very entertaining there's there's
heartfelt moments I think we run the
gamut I think it's it's packed with a
lot of awesome moments now this will be
the most unique it will be the most
complex show and it just might be the
most fun and entertaining 12 minutes
this world has ever seen and if this
carpool karaoke moment with James
Corden's dad is any sign of what's to
come on Sunday we are surely in for a
treat don't be fooled by the rise that I
guess I'm still I'm still Jenny when a
block is a little know you in wrong key
here's what Jennifer told et about
playing the Super Bowl just before she
and Shakira were announced as headliners
in September when your little girl in
your dreaming
you know want to be an actress so you
want to be a singer there's certain like
things that you hope to accomplish one
day and that's definitely one of them
[Music]